Any video game fans here?
(audience cheering)
Well, this is pretty exciting,
the new Xbox One X console comes out tomorrow,
it's the most powerful...
I know, most powerful console in the world
and to help us all feel the true power of the new console,
please welcome my friend, Ronda Rousey.
Hey!
(audience applauding and cheering)
Amazing.
You look fantastic by the way.
Thank you.
It is so, it is so great to see you, Ronda.
Could you please explain to us, who's this guy right here?
This is Dustin and he's going to help us demonstrate
exactly what it feels like to experience
true 4K gaming on the Xbox One X console.
Are you ready, Dustin?
Mm-hmm.
Okay, you guys all ready to see this?
(audience clapping and cheering)
Why don't you, show them, Ronda.
Here we go.
Oh!
Like that.
That was awesome!
You see, everyone look at that!
You see Andy's reaction?
That, is what it feels like to
play the new Xbox One X console.
Now let's show them what it's like to play with friends.
(groaning)
Ronda Rousey, everybody, thanks, we'll be right back.
(lively music)
(hitting sound effects)